well kids absolutely adore Marvel movies
there's a lot about this franchise that
only grown-ups will appreciate from
tacky outfits and glossed over
casualties to an incessant barrage of
quick-witted innuendos here are some
things in the MCU that only adults will
notice between the mythological gods
radioactive monsters and talking mark
UN's
it's pretty obvious that no one is going
into a Marvel movie looking for a dose
of realism when it comes to space travel
though believability gets stretched
pretty far even by the goofiest sci-fi
standards at this point a fair number of
humans have been shown making trips to
space sometimes this has very real
consequences like when Tony Stark nearly
died from a lack of oxygen or when pizza
Parker had to be saved before he was
yanked out of the atmosphere by the
black hoard of spaceship at other times
though any of the problems of being in
space or on an alien planet are
completely ignored and our very human
heroes get to Thanos his homeworld of
Titan and Avengers infinity war they're
able to breathe just fine on an alien
planet the same goes for for Mia when
Hawkeye and black widow head over there
an endgame to find everything hunky-dory
physiologically speaking the movie spend
a lot of time on the pseudoscience that
explains all of the strange phenomena
throughout the MCU
but space travel seems to operate
entirely on whatever seems convenient
for the plots kids might not notice but
if you're old enough to have taken a
science class or even read the original
Infinity Gauntlet comics while
suffocating in the vacuum of space is a
pretty big concern to any superhero
battles it's an easy detail to get hung
up on in most of their films the Marvel
masterminds of money to keep a core of
something believable in the context of
the very unbelievable stories Captain
America Civil War sent us on a very
realistic showdown built around
relatable ideas of loyalty and betrayal
even if it also involves flying androids
robotic power armor and teenagers with
spider strength in spite of it all the
serious tone of the film draws the
audience past all that and into that
emotional core that doesn't change the
fact that many of the super rogue
struggles taking place throughout the
MCU our ridiculously lopsided however
take the fight with Thanos on Titan and
the game shows us a he's a villain that
can hold his own against super powerful
characters like Captain Marvel even
without the Infinity Gauntlet but an
infinity war the mad Titan spend several
minutes struggling against characters
like Drax and star-lord sure Drax is
strong but he's not strong enough to
destroy an entire fleet of spaceships
with his bare hands and Peter quill is
really just a guy with laser guns and a
comprehensive knowledge of classic rock
they're not exactly the biggest threats
it's not just a fight scene either you
can see the wildly imbalanced
superpowers on display just by looking
at the Avengers on the one hand you have
characters like Black Widow and Hawkeye
who are incredibly skilled and deadly by
regular human standards on the other
hand you have the Hulk who can punch out
space monsters the size of a battleship
and Thor the literal god of thunder kids
like to see or their favorite standing
shoulder-to-shoulder but as adults we
have to ask it's Clint Barton really
contributing a whole lot to the fight it
doesn't matter if you're witnessing the
epic climax of the film or even a fight
between the heroes themselves super
heroic battles are almost always a focus
of these movies the consequences of
those battles however all over the map
sometimes are lasting effects of a major
encounter play an important part of the
story like the destruction of sokovia in
Avengers age of Ultron that one is
treated as a massive tragedy with huge
ramifications for the rest of the
universe for every scene like this
however there are a dozen that never
really bring up all the collateral
damage that comes along with trashing
armies of alien drones or swinging
around magic hammers the Battle of New
York and Avengers for instance is shown
to be so devastating that the world
Security Council is willing to nuke
Manhattan which has to indicate a
ridiculous number of casualties and yet
once a credits roll it's never brought
up again the same goes for the end of
Captain America the Winter Soldier where
shield Hallie carriers are dropping out
of the sky over Washington DC and then
to the Potomac River these are
incredibly destructive events in highly
populated areas and as adults the secona
thing we tend to think about winter out
of the theater here's a fun fact if
you're under the age of say a teen then
you've never really experienced a pop
culture landscape that didn't feature
the MCU
the characters on the other hand that
seemed pretty well acquainted with the
movies I hit theaters long before Tony
Stark built himself a suit of super
armor in a cave even the younger ones
hey guys
[Music]
last week that Jesus Tony how old I
don't know I didn't carbon-dated meat on
the young side the superheroes of the
Marvel Universe are always throwing our
references to classic movies from Peter
Parker's love of the Star Wars trilogy
to Tony Stark referring to thoris Point
Break we've even seen Captain Marvel
crashing down to earth and a Blockbuster
Video which for those youngsters among
you was sort of like a Netflix that you
had to physically drive to and you could
only watch the movie you wanted if you
got there before everyone else got off
work that's exactly the kind of
reference our today's kids just aren't
going to understand we've come a long
way from the x-men films of the early
2000s but the characters swapped out
their familiar brightly colored comic
costumes for allegedly functional black
leather outfits you actually go outside
what would you prefer yellow spandex
these days we've all gotten used to
seeing superhero showing up on screen
looking just like their source material
but that doesn't change the fact that
their outfits are often straight-up
ridiculous
that doesn't mean they look bad though
without those colorful suits the MCU
would wind up being a pretty drab place
it's just that we never quite get why
nobody chooses to dress in something a
little more practical just look at Steve
Rogers original costume is meant to be
well a costume it's specifically made
for his onstage appearances selling war
bonds when he goes into action however
he dresses more like a soldier
for about five minutes he's then given a
slightly more functional version of a
stage costume and for some reason sticks
with it when he wakes up in the 21st
century - even when he goes on the
ground after the events of Civil War he
keeps the same suit and just takes up
all the white parts to go over the cool
new beard for a kid or that makes sense
cap looks like that because that's just
what Captain America looks like for the
cynic or critical adult eyes though we
have to wonder why he doesn't just dress
in a more tactical outfits and for that
matter why Tony Stark doesn't just build
everyone on the team a suit of armor
especially the ones who are very
vulnerable to getting shots can't have
it Captain America Civil War is a great
movie it has one of the franchise's most
memorable battles introduced it's not
one but two brand-new major characters
to the MCU
picks up on plot threads from age of
Ultron and thighs together the entire
Marvel Cinematic Universe while still
focusing on his title character and how
far is willing to go to help his friends
it also seems on the surface like it's a
perfect movie for kids to get excited
about
after all spider-man has always been a
favorite for younger fans and what kid
wouldn't be excited to see ant-man
growing up to giant size during that
unforgettable Airport battle in Germany
the rest of the movie on the other hand
might not be ideal for that particular
audience
in addition that being built around the
fact that Captain America's best friend
just straight-up murder diamonds mom and
dad most of the plot of civil war is a
debate about government oversights
that's exciting it is to see Captain
America bicep curling a helicopter
having two characters argue over whether
they should submit to Authority or
remain independent in order to follow
their own moral compass and pursue a
more proactive interventionist policy is
well it's not exactly what the
elementary school set has excited about
and that's before you get to the part
where the main villain is doing
everything simply because he craves
death yikes
fortunately anyone who was a little too
young for all that probably just
remembers how cool it was when ant-man
wrote in Hawkeye zero it's just like the
comics it's not a usual for a movie that
appeals to kids to throw in some jokes
for the grown-ups in the audience and
with the kind of cross generational
appeal that has led to record-breaking
box-office totals the MCU movies are no
exception the thing is that these movies
all those adult jokes are twelve really
adult especially when they're coming
from Tony Stark and Peter Quayle I am
man always has a sarcastic record ready
for any situation like when he asks
Black Widow and Hulk FL playing hide the
zucchini or when he took a swipe at
Hawkeye for having a little difficulty
lifting up the onea we won't hold it
against you if you can't get it up
star-lord on the other hand makes Tony
look like he could be teaching Sunday
school in a movie that features are
talking ma-kun you know for the kids
yeah
the Guardians leader mentions that a
starship would look a lot like a Jackson
Pollock painting underneath the
backlight if you're an adult you already
get it and that's just a tip of the
innuendo iceberg fortunately these are
exactly the kind of jokes that are going
to go right over the kids heads unless
of course they have reflexes like Drax
nothing goes over my head my reflexes
are too fast if the past 10 years have
proven anything is like kids love
Ironman there are plenty of reasons why
- he's a modern-day Knight in literal
shining armor with a seemingly endless
personal fortune and enough smarts to
literally invent a new element that his
basement
he's a cool exec with a heart of Steel
and takes spider-man likes him - so will
the other kid should - right
not exactly Tony Stark's entire
character arc over the course of 10
years of movies it's built around some
very adult oriented themes many of which
might be missed by younger viewers who
are busy focusing on the glitz and
glamour of the Iron Man armor the man
started as a playboy he was constantly
womanizing and drinking without a care
in the world he treated people like
garbage and didn't blink twice the more
struggle of living off of a fortune
built on dealing weapons even after he
made his change and started to reforge
his personality into one of the greatest
superheroes in the entire MCU his story
remains just as adult in nature in age
of Ultron he dealt with a world that was
suddenly a whole lot bigger than he
thought by making huge mistakes and thy
Man 3 is a movie entirely about
post-traumatic stress disorder even in
his final moments his inner struggles
continued until he accepted that it had
to sacrifice his own life and any chance
of seeing his daughter grow up to save
everyone else without a doubt the
quantity of high-minded adult level
material in the stark storyline is
overwhelming but hey the armors pretty
cool right check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]